hey guys my name is just McDonald it is
the 6th of August today and your
children to gamespot news Activision
have completed the call of duty and
destiny probably appealed to the same
group of gamers but they don't see this
getting in the way of their respective
blockbuster status on how many games the
industry can support and particularly
the first-person action genre I think
we've seen in the past that the
first-person action genre in particular
is broadly appealing enough to
accommodate more than one blockbuster
hit there have been other good
performing players in that genre and
that hasn't ever kept call of duty from
delivering incredible results he also
identified that while both games are
classified as FPS titles they're very
different in style narrative and
atmosphere if the glint of Assassin's
Creed rogue has been catching your eye
you'll probably want to tune into this
mess of new details the game's extensive
preview in Game Informer September issue
indicates that road will be skipping
multiplayer this makes it the first
assassin's creed game to do so since AC
to a bunch of other interesting details
include the fact that the protagonist
begins the first section of the game
undergoing missions as an assassin
before deciding to leave the order and
become a Templar there will also be a
tie-in with Assassin's Creed unity
toward the end of the game your ship is
called the Morgan there's a whole mess
of ship combat features and you can hunt
polar bears and no walls for the full
list of details check out our story on
gamespot and in what is far and away my
favorite story of the day everything he
knew about yoshi is a lie because you're
she is nothing but a nickname like
harris author of console wars discovered
the characters full name in a Nintendo
character guide from 1993 in all things
unbelievably adorable the little green
enemy munching dinosaur is actually
named T yo she saw munchakoopas the
mystery isn't all dead though since we
have no idea what the T stands for your
best guess is welcome or your worst
guess which ever interestingly the guide
also says that Mario isn't human at all
but a different species he does fall
into the same genus as us regular humans
but his species is
spied as Nintendo pneus presumably
something along the lines of he who
traverses great colorful planes but
never quit his plumber day job the story
goes that Mario saved yoshi or tea from
an egg by jumping on him obviously and
then they became friends and set out to
save Yoshi's dinosaur Bros from Bowser
still a better love story than Twilight
ask your question of the day let me know
down in the comments what you think the
T stands for in you she's named those
are all the things I wanted to tell you
about today but be sure to tune in same
time again tomorrow and have a good one
till then